لقد تحولت قاعدة رامشتاين الجوية بسرعة
إلى ملجأ مؤقت للأشخاص
الذين تم إجلاؤهم من أفغانستان ،
لذا فمن وجهة النظر
هذه يمكنك أن ترى مدى نمو هذه
العملية عندما وصلنا إلى هنا
صباح يوم السبت لرؤية تلك الرحلات القليلة الأولى التي
وصلت هناك فقط عدد قليل
أعشار هناك الآن كما ترون
لقد نمت وتوضح حقًا
ما هي العملية الضخمة التي تهدف إلى
جلب الآلاف من الأشخاص الذين تم
إجلاؤهم ، وقد تضخم العدد الذي ينتظر الآن هنا
إلى سبعة آلاف منهم جميعًا يائسين
للوصول إلى الولايات المتحدة.
تقول إنها قاتلت في طريقها
إلى مطار كابول لإخراج جميع النساء في
عائلتها ،
لقد رأينا الكثير من المشاكل هنا وأنا فقط
أحاول وحاولت عائلتي الخروج
لأننا جميعًا نساء ولا يوجد رجال
معنا
لأننا كنا فقط  امرأة
وشقيقي هنا فينا ، لذلك نحاول الذهاب
والوصول إليهم
يكون عبورًا سريعًا يستغرق الآن وقتًا أطول بكثير.
يتم
إعطاء الأولوية لعيسى وفقًا
لوزارة الخارجية ، لكن نظيف ميوان أخبرنا أن
لديه تأشيرة وكان ينتظر أكثر
من يومين للصعود على متن رحلة
نحن بحاجة للاستحمام ، نحتاج إلى
الإنترنت ، الإنترنت غير
متاح هنا بطريقة ما نحتاج إلى ذلك  لديك
اتصال مع أفراد عائلتنا
لأنهم قلقون
بشأننا ،
فنحن لسنا مرتاحين للغاية هنا ، الأمور
ليست جيدة هنا ، وأنا أعلم
أنهم يبذلون قصارى
جهدهم لتسريع التعبئة ،
وقد قام البنتاغون بتنشيط المدنية  أسطول جوي احتياطي
به شركات طيران تجارية مثل
دلتا لإحضار الأشخاص الذين تم إجلاؤهم إلينا ، ولكن
اعتبارًا من ليلة الثلاثاء ، لم يتم سوى عدد قليل من
الرحلات الجوية من رامشتاين
مع وجود ما مجموعه عدة مئات فقط على
متن
[موسيقى]
في هذه الأثناء يغنيون و  تبقي كرة القدم
الصغار مشغولين
بينما يقلق آباؤهم وينتظرون
أتيكو شوبرت من أجل CNN في قاعدة رامشتاين
الجوية في ألمانيا
[تصفيق]